[Music]
g2 eSports are the best team that
Rainbow six siege has ever seen Pro
League the major three Mac you name it
and they've won it in the six
Invitational sieges most coveted
tournament well these guys are
back-to-back champions
[Applause]
[Applause]
now heading into this year's
Invitational G to have the opportunity
to expand their already insane legacy by
winning a third consecutive title but
fans aren't talking about whether or not
they're gonna win or lose fans are
talking about whether they deserve to
even be at the Invitational in the first
place I think no matter what with you
even if we go clean sweep this entire
Pony season I still don't think that
justifies the invite as valid I still
think no matter what if we get it it's
gonna be a pity in life as Penta these
guys ran through Europe winning their
first Invitational with a crazy reverse
sweep against Evil Geniuses
a few months later and g2 picked them up
kicking off an era of dominance that
siege has never seen before the six
major Paris pro league season 8 and
Dreamhack winter if g2 were there you
knew who was gonna win to solidify their
rule over competitive seed g2 won their
second Invitational this time against
team Empire g2 slump began at pro league
season 9 Europe where they ended the
group stage in third place failing to
advance to the global finals next came
the Raleigh major in August four months
after their Pro League misstep g2 were
ready to make a comeback and they came
this close but they couldn't get it done
team Empire took them out in the finals
Joystiq still not aware Brad but it is
to kill street for Shepard and the
Empire Strikes Back they will take the
Roli major unlike their Pro League lost
though g2 second place at Raleigh cost
them an invite to this year's
Invitational
luckily g2 still had four more chances
to grab an invite and their next
opportunity came at Dreamhack Montreal
where they failed to make it out of
groups then there was pro league season
10 where g2 once again came in third
narrowly missing the finals and an
invite to the Invitational with only two
more opportunities to earn a spot via
the og a pit and the European qualifier
g2 made the controversial decision to
drop their legendary support Doga sadly
the roster changed in work and g2 were
knocked out of both events cryin was not
the answer and if you if you heard what
the players had said cryin was not their
first pick they couldn't get a lot of
the players because the players they
wanted were on other teams and those
teams either wouldn't let them go or
those players didn't want to go at this
point G twos last shot at attending SI
was from a direct invite from ubisoft
themselves something Pangu didn't really
want I don't want to get invited sir
hitting inviting this [ __ ]
Viking over there so bad you couldn't
quantify here's an imitation dude yeah
hyper stare hope that we don't get in
like that's my hope but surprising
literally no one lubis off gave g2 the
invite anyway allowing the back-to-back
champions to defend their crown look
honestly things don't look good for g2
clion the guy who replaced Goga was
benched 12 days before the tournament
and g2 is using a stand-in and instead
but Pangu Fabian and Kanto are still
champions these guys know what it takes
to win if there was anyone who could
pull off such a miracle and siege it
would be these guys the core of that
squad which is now Canterbury K do you
know Kent over KT Fabien and Penghu I
think it's probably still one of the
strongest cores in the history of this
eSport and come the Invitational it
doesn't matter if you're the first in
the world or you're a wild card in
but all that matters is who raises the
hammer thanks for watching if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you will
find anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]